I think he's gonna be a fantastic
representative of our team he's highly
respected by everybody in this room john
bolton is only a week into his new job
but he's already emerging as a first
among equals solidifying his power by
ousting four key national security
players in just four days
national security experts tell FOX News
Bolton is now considering merging the
national security council and homeland
security council's the two most
important offices inside the White House
that make US foreign policy it's a move
that's been tried in the past President
Obama had inherited this system that had
been set up under President Bush
separate Homeland Security Council which
was established after the attacks in
September of 2001 and so we took a hard
look at whether it made sense to keep
them as separate staffs or to merge the
two staffs together experts say the move
gives Alton more control and could make
in the primary West Wing voice in the
president's Iran foreign policy I have
my views I'm sure I'll have a chance to
articulate them to the president given
Bolton's tough stance on China Russia
Iran combating terrorism and nuclear
development insiders predict even more
aggressive policies but what if
president Trump's confidant says Bowman
is just what the nation needs he is not
going to always agree with this
president and that's a great thing that
we're gonna have someone who is
instinctively much more in the Reagan
model of peace through strength
surprisingly some senior Obama officials
agree with Bolton's plan if I were the
national security adviser for any
president I would want that kind of
integration to ensure that everything is
coming through me ultimately and that I
would be accountable to the president
for all of those issues this move may
sound like just another wonky
development for Washington insiders to
chew over but it's actually got
implications for US policy abroad with
Bossert out Bolton now manages his
former portfolio that includes
counterterrorism cyber security and
border security issues